[Música]
en revista de prensa con Rosa Pérez
Mateo vamos a hablar de un supuesto
mensaje de lis Rush que causa polémica
en la prensa rusa y británica de que
estamos hablando exactamente de rosa muy
buena mañana de jueves Buenos días Raúl
si es un tema bien complejo empecemos
por el principio como se suele decir
bien este sábado Rusia recordemos que
acusó a Reino Unido de estar implicado
tanto en los ataques que se dieron ese
mismo día este sábado pasado con
hadrones supuestamente ucranianos sobre
la Bahía de sebastopol en el mar Negro
de la Península de crimea como de estar
implicado también en las explosiones que
tuvieron lugar el 26 de septiembre en
los gasoductos nordstream y nordstream 2
bien esta polémica se escaló cuando el
domingo en la propietario de Mega y el
usuario con muchísimos seguidores en
twitter.com publicó en esta red social
que les habría mandado un mensaje a
Anthony blinken al secretario de estado
de Estados Unidos diciendo It's done
está hecho instantes después de las
explosiones en los gasoductos como
decíamos no estrimuno y nostrildos y
cómo se sabría este supuesto mensaje de
la existencia de esta comunicación entre
la que entonces era la primera ministra
de Reino Unido y el secretario de estado
de Estados Unidos bien porque el usuario
iCloud la nube de Apple de listas
estaría hackeada desde el verano desde
el verano europeo bien como decíamos de
momento nos están aportando pruebas de
esta comunicación sin embargo ya se da
prácticamente por hecha sobre todo por
parte de las autoridades rusas que piden
explicaciones y así lo destaca RT dice
el kremlin tiene pruebas de la
participación británica en este
sabotaque Sabotaje en los gasoductos
como decíamos al norsem y así lo
defendió Dimitri Scott el martes después
de que hubiera salido este sobre esta
comunicación este mensaje por otro lado
María sacarova portavoz del Ministerio
de exteriores de Rusia pidió
explicaciones a Londres sobre este
supuesto mensaje dijo que millones de
personas en el mundo tienen derecho a
saber qué sucedió con la seguridad
energética mundial por otro lado el
medio económico ruso comersante publica
hoy mismo que el secretario del Consejo
de Seguridad de la federación rusa
hablamos de nicolay patricef reunido con
representantes de la comunidad de
Estados independientes dijo que el
mensaje detrás sugiere la participación
de la marina del Reino Unido en los
ataques contra el nordstream también
aseguró que Reino Unido trabaja con
Estados Unidos que es el principal
beneficiario de los sabotajes en estos
gasoductos por otro lado pasamos a la
prensa británica el Daily mail dice
titula por la parte de que Estados
Unidos considera ridícula esta acusación
no que considera que no está
fundamentada la existencia de este
mensaje sin embargo el Daily mail
destaca que ellos mismos que este propio
periódico que este mismo periódico
reveló que el móvil de listras estaba
hackeado en verano sin embargo en ese
momento listas no era ni siquiera
primera ministra de Londres de Reino
Unido todavía no sino que era todavía
secretaría de exteriores bajo la
administración de Boris Johnson entonces
defiende este medio que es poco probable
que listas hubiera continuado utilizando
una cuenta o un dispositivo hackeado no
bien y por otro lado la bbc se aleja y a
radicalmente del tema del mensaje y lo
que publica al respecto Es que la
oposición pide una investigación sobre
el hackeo del móvil detrás Y porque el
gobierno lo ocultó bueno Rosa vamos a
cambiar entonces de información vamos a
hablar de hilo hermoso porque están
revelando diversos medios de
comunicación no que quiere reducir el
personal que trabaja en actualidad
Júpiter a la mitad Rosa exactamente y es
así lo revela hoy el financial Times que
dice que y lo Mask para finales de esta
semana es decir para mañana o incluso
antes podría ser en horas horas
exactamente planea despedir a unos 3.700
empleados lo que sería la mitad de los
7.000 la de 500 que trabajan en Twitter
y que a partir del lunes también el que
el nuevo propietario que ya está a los
amandos de esta red social también
planea obligar a los trabajadores a
volver a la oficina bueno y el South of
china morning poster repasa también la
cambiante relación entre elon musk y el
ex presidente Donald Trump a lo largo de
los últimos años exactamente porque
Bueno es un tema que está sobre la mesa
con lo que con la primavera
con la preocupación actual de que haya
un incremento de la violencia política
de Cara a estas legislativas recordemos
que a Trump Le suspendieron la cuenta de
Twitter tras el asalto del 6 de enero de
2021 y también puede hablar de fraude
Exacto recurrentes acusaciones
infundadas de fraude electoral en las
elecciones de 2020 y por eso mismo el
sauchaina morning pues repasa la
relación que titula califica de montañas
rusa entre los dos multimillonarios dice
el expresidente estadounidense y el
hombre más rico del mundo pasan de ser
mejores amigos a insultarse no ambos
empresarios comparten animadversión
hacia la izquierda y una tendencia
fanfarronear en línea pero su relación
no es fácil bien para repasar algunos
episodios de esta turbulenta relación en
noviembre de 2016 Mask dijo que Trump no
Debería ser presidente Pero en diciembre
de ese mismo año aceptó ser miembro de
uno de los consejos económicos del
presidenciales ya de Donald Trump sin
embargo en julio de 2017 cortó lazos con
la Casa Blanca por estar en desacuerdo
con las políticas ambientales de la
Administración Trump y
enero de 2020 Trump dijo que más que es
uno de los mayores ge de Estados Unidos
en mayo de 2022 más dijo que cuando
fuera propietario de Twitter devolvería
la cuenta a Donald Trump sin embargo en
julio dijo que no debería Trump volver a
presentarse como presidente y Trump dijo
que más era un Ball shift artist no bien
en este octubre Trump dijo que se
alegraba de que más que estuviera al
frente de Twitter y no que esta red
social estuviera en manos de
izquierdistas lunáticos pero que no
planea volver que prefiere su propia red
social desde la que critica recordemos
tanto a tesla como spacex Bueno una
relación de amor egido Dios y cerramos
con la editorial del medio cubano Granma
Rosa sí que titula qué poco Estados
Unidos respeta al mundo al mantener el
bloqueo sobre Cuba y es un artículo en
inglés precisamente porque hoy Como cada
año desde hace 30 años la asamblea
general de Naciones Unidas vota una
resolución presentada por la Habana en
la que piden el levantamiento del
embargo que Estados Unidos impone sobre
isla y por eso mismo no porque cada año
una amplísima mayoría de países del
Mundo votan a favor de que Estados
Unidos levante el embargo sobre Cuba y
Estados Unidos aún así no lo hace este
medio Granma considera que es una falta
total de respeto Por la comunidad
internacional solo para recordar la
votación del año pasado 184 países
votaron a favor de levantar el embargo
dos en contra Estados Unidos y Israel y
tres abstenciones Colombia Ucrania y
Brasil se espera que Colombia al menos
cambie de bando este claro Gracias Rosa
como siempre por toda la información de
revista de prensa mañana más